[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so this game is very simple
all you have to do is read what you see
right so i'm going to count you so we
don't all do it all do it together okay
one two three
amazing what about this one one two
three
all right one two three
if you were portuguese right how about
this one one two three
what are you reading there are no words
there
i said read what you're seeing right it
literally says
right that's what you should have said
right why is this
it's because perception is grounded in
our experience
right the brain takes meaningless
information
and makes meaning out of it which means
we never see what's there
we never see information we only ever
see what was useful to see in the past
right which means when it comes to
perception we're all like this frog
right it's getting information it's
general behavior that's useful
and sometimes when things don't go our
way we get a little bit annoyed right
but we're talking about perception here
right
perception underpins everything we think
we know we believe our hopes our dreams
the clothes we wear
falling in love everything begins with
perception
now if perception is grounded in our
history it means we're only ever
responding
according to what we've done before but
that creates a tremendous problem
because how can we ever see differently
now i want to tell you a story about
seeing differently
and all new perceptions begin in the
same way
they begin with a question the problem
with questions
is they create uncertainty now
uncertainty is a very bad thing it's
evolutionary a bad thing if you're not
sure that's a predator it's too late
okay even seasickness is a consequence
of uncertainty
right if you go down below in a boat
your inner ears are telling you are
moving
your eyes because it's moving in
register with a boat say i'm standing
still
your brain cannot deal with the
uncertainty of that information and it
gets ill
the question why is one of the most
dangerous things you can do
because it takes you into uncertainty
and yet
the irony is the only way we can ever do
anything new is to step into that space
so how can we ever do anything new well
fortunately
evolution has given us an answer right
and it
enables us to address even the most
difficult
of questions the best questions are the
ones that create the most uncertainty
they're the ones that question the
things we think to be true already
right it's easy to ask questions about
how did life begin or what extends
you're on the universe but to question
what you think to be true already
is really stepping into that space so
what is evolution's
answer to the problem of uncertainty
it's play now play is not simply a
process
experts in play will tell you that
actually it's a way of being
play is one of the only human endeavors
where uncertainty is actually celebrated
uncertainty is what makes play fun right
it's adaptable to change right it opens
possibility
and it's cooperative it's actually how
we do our social bonding and it's
intrinsically motivated what that means
is that we play to play plays its own
reward
now if you look at these five ways of
being
these are the exact same ways of being
you need in order to be a good scientist
science is not defined by the method
section of a paper it's actually a way
of being
which is here and this is true for
anything that is creative
so if you add rules to play you have a
game
that's actually what an experiment is so
armed with these two ideas
that science is a way of being and
experiments are play
we asked can anyone become a scientist
and who better to ask than 25 8 to 10
year old children because they're
experts in play
so i took my b arena down to a small
school in devon
and the aim of this was to not just get
the kids to see science differently
but through the process of science to
see themselves differently
right the first step was to ask a
question
now i should say that we didn't get
funding for this study because
the scientists said small children could
make useful contribution to science
and the teachers said kids couldn't do
it so we did it anyway
right of course so here are some of the
questions i put them in small print so
you wouldn't bother reading it
point is that five of the questions that
the kids came up with
were actually the basis of science
publication the last five to 15 years
right so they were asking questions that
were significant to expert scientists
now here i want to share the stage with
someone quite special
right she was one of the young people
was involved in study
and she's now one of the youngest
published scientists in the world
right she will now once she comes onto
stage will be the youngest person to
ever
speak at ted right now science and
asking questions about courage
now she is the personification of
courage because she's going to stand up
here and talk to you all
so amy would you please come up
[Applause]
[Music]
so amy is going to help me tell the
story of what we call the black open
bees project
and first she's going to tell you the
question that they came up with so go
ahead amy thank you
we thought that it was easy to see the
link between humans
and apes in the way that we think
because we look alike
but we wondered if there's a possible
link with other animals
it'd be amazing if humans and bees
thought similar
since they seemed so different from us
so we asked if humans and bees might
solve complex problems
in the same way really we want to know
if bees
can also adapt themselves to new
situations
using previous land rules and conditions
so what if bees can think like us well
it'd be amazing since we're talking
about an
insect with only one million brain cells
but actually makes a lot of sense they
should
because bees like us can recognize a
good foul
regardless of the time of day the light
the weather
or from any angler approaching from
so the next step was to design an
experiment
which is a game so the kids went off and
they designed this experiment
and so that well game and so amy can you
tell us what the game was
in the puzzle that you set the bees the
puzzle we came up with was an
if then we'll we have to beat the land
not just to go to a certain color
but to a certain color flower only when
it's in a certain pattern
they will only rewarded if they went to
the yellow flowers
if the yellow flowers were surrounded by
the blue or
if the blue flowers were surrounded by
the yellow now there's a number of
different rules the bees will land solve
this puzzle
the interesting question is which what
was really exciting about this project
was we
and beau had no idea whether it was work
it was completely new and no one had
done it before
including adults
including the teachers and that was
really hard for the teachers it's easy
for a scientist to go and not have a
clue what he's doing
because that's what we do in the lab but
for a teacher not to know what's going
to happen at the end of the day
so much of the credit goes to dave
strudwick who is the collaborator on
this project
okay so i'm not going to go through the
whole details of the study because
actually you can read it read about it
but the next step is observation so here
are
some of the students doing the
observations they're recording the data
of where the bees fly
can you help me henry what good
scientist says that right
[Music]
right so we've got our observations
we've got our data they do the simple
mathematics averaging etc etc and now we
want to share that's the next step so
we're going to write this up and try to
submit this for publication
right so we have to write it up so we go
of course to the pub
all right the one on the left is mine
okay now i tell them a paper has four
different sections an introduction of
methods
a results a discussion the introduction
says what's the question and why
methods what did you do results what was
the observation and the discussion is
who cares
right that's a science paper basically
so
the kids give me the words right i put
it into a narrative
which means that this paper is written
in kidspeak it's not written by me
it's written by amy and the other
students in the class
as a consequence the science paper
begins once upon a time
the results section it says training
phase the puzzle
right and the methods it says then we
put the bees into the fridge and maybe
pie
smiley face right this is a science
paper we're going to try to get it
published
so here's the title page we have a
number of authors there all the ones in
bold are eight to ten years old
the first author is black open primary
school because if forever reference it
would be black open
ethel and not one individual so we
submit it to a
public access journal and it says this
it said many things but it said this i'm
afraid the paper fails our initial
quality control checks in several
different ways in other words it starts
off once upon a time
the figures in crayon etc so we decide
we'll get it reviewed so i send it to
dale
purvis who's the national academy of
science one of the leading
neuroscientists in the world
and he says this is the most original
scientific paper i've ever read
and it certainly deserves wide exposure
larry maloney
expert in vision says the paper is
magnificent the work would be
publishable if done by adults
so what do we do we send it back to the
editor they say no
so we asked larry and natalie to hempel
to write a commentary
situating the findings for scientists
right
putting in the references and we
submitted to biology letters
and there it was reviewed by five
independent referees
and it was published okay
[Applause]
[Music]
it took four months to do the science
two years
to get it published typical science
actually
right so this makes amy and her friends
the youngest published scientists in the
world what was the feedback like
well it was published two days before
christmas downloaded 30
000 times in the first day right
it was the editor's choice in science
which is a top science magazine
it's forever freely accessible by biola
jewelers it's only paper that will ever
be freely accessible
by this journal last year was the second
most downloaded paper
by biology letters and the feedback from
not just scientists
and teachers but the public as well and
i'll just read one
i have read black ops recently i don't
have words to explain exactly how i'm
feeling right now
what you guys have done is real true and
amazing curiosity interests innocence
and zeal
are the most basic most important things
to do with science who else can have
these qualities more than children
please congratulate your children's team
from my side
so i'd like to conclude with a physical
metaphor
can i do it on you okay okay yeah
come on yeah yeah okay now science is
about taking risks so this is incredible
risk
right for me not for him right because
we've only done this once before
and you like technology right right so
this is the this is myself this is
epitome of technology
right okay now
okay now
we're gonna do a little demonstration
right
you have to close your eyes and you have
to point
where you hear me clapping all right
okay how about if everyone over there
shouts one two three
really now open your eyes we'll do it
one more time
everyone over there shout where's the
sound coming from
thank you very much
what's the point the point is what
science does for us right
we normally walk through life responding
but if we ever want to do anything
different we have to step into
uncertainty
when he opened his eyes he was able to
see the world in a new way
that's what science offers us it offers
the possibility to step on uncertainty
through the process of play right now
true science education
i think should be about giving people a
voice and enabling to express that voice
so i've asked amy
to be the last voice in this short story
so amy
this project was really exciting for me
because it brought the process of
discovery to life they show me that
anyone and i mean anyone has the
potential to discover something new
and that a small question can lead to a
big discovery
changing the way a person thinks about
something can be easy
or hard it all depends on the way the
person feels about change
but changing the way i thought about
science was surprisingly easy
once we played the games and then
started to think about the puzzle
i then realized that science isn't just
a boring subject
and that anyone can discover something
new
you just need an opportunity my
opportunity came in the form of bow
and the black autumn bee project thank
you very much
[Applause]
you